if the government were ever to digitize
currency your freedoms would evaporate
they could zero out your bank account
and make you impoverished for being
disobedient you would be a surf at best
and with that in mind you should know
that Central Bank digital currencies
cbdc's are about to become the Norman
Europe the president of the European
Central Bank Christine Lagarde has just
said that Europeans will not be able to
use more than a thousand dollars in cash
anymore
now we have in Europe This threshold
above 1 000 Euros you cannot pay cash if
you do you're on the gray Market you
take your risk you get the code you are
fine or you go in jail
so you go to jail for spending your own
money if they don't control it
that's coming here Tulsi gabbard has
spoken out against it she of course ran
for president served in the house from
Hawaii and joins us now Congressman
thanks so much for coming on thanks
Tucker this is so dystopian you'd hate
to think you could ever come here you
think it might
uh well yeah I mean this is just the
latest effort by those in power in our
country who are intent on undermining
and taking away our own freedoms and
Liberties this this Central Bank digital
currency is about government sanction
surveillance and control it's about them
being able to keep track of every single
thing that we purchase whether it's a
stick of gum or an automobile or
anything in between and so if they have
all this info information and data which
they will in this system then where does
that lead it gives them the power to
decide okay well hey we don't want to
allow you to purchase certain things or
we may deem it necessary to to freeze
your overall account
this power and what they can do with it
it's not something we have to imagine
we've already seen how Democrats in
Congress Elizabeth Warren and others are
pressuring credit card companies to code
and keep track of any purchase that's
made at a store that sells Firearms why
so that these private companies can then
say hey this person person is purchasing
I don't know what their what they deem
is kind of the threshold but there's
they will then report that a suspicious
activity to law enforcement and then
expect law enforcement to take action
and go after the purchases legal legal
purchase that a private person made so
this all comes back to to how you open
this once we give up our economic
autonomy we no longer have freedom once
we allow someone else to control our
wallet they then control our freedom
do you think people understand what this
means it'll be sold as always as an
effort to push back against terrorism or
International
Finance seers or crime or whatever but
do people understand on a gut level what
could be coming I I don't think they do
and and it's understandable because if
you listen to what the government is
telling us like with all of these other
things whether it's the Patriot Act or
the restrict act they're doing the very
same thing with this saying hey this is
for your own good this is for your
convenience to make it easier for you to
conduct transactions uh when in fact
they're giving themselves all of the
Power uh taking it away from us
undermining our god-given rights and
freedoms in the Constitution uh because
they want to be able to control us they
want to be able to control We the People
so nicely put Tulsi Gabbert joining us
tonight thank you so much for that
thanks Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight